[Музика]
Привіт, мене звати Наталія Супава, і настав
час для нашого уроку англійської мови,
тому я сподіваюся, що ви всі
щасливі та здорові, тому що ми знаємо,
що
для цього нам потрібен спорт і здорове харчування
і ми продовжуємо говорити про спорт
на початку, давайте подивимося, що ми вже
навчилися
, подивіться на ці зображення, я сподіваюся,
що ви вже
знаєте назву цього порту, як використовувати гру,
що займається різними видами спорту,
дайте мені причину, чому  вам подобаються чи не
подобаються
різні види спорту або навіть розказуєте
про свій поганий хороший досвід у
спорті,
ми, звісно, зробили деякі граматики, де
кі модальні роботи, прислівники та пр
кметники, і ми знаємо, як
ути кращими та найкращими, ви
ористовуючи порівняння  Греція, і
тепер ми знаємо, хто найшвидша людина
в світі, а також ми знаємо,
що повільний бігун може виграти гонку, якщо він або
вона
продовжує тренуватися і наполегливо працювати,
тому ми дізналися, що спорт може бути
небезпечним,
але ми знаємо, що нам робити  з цим
ми знаємо як  багато м’язів, які ми використовуємо, коли ми
говоримо англійською,
а також ми переглянули
стародавні Олімпійські ігри і
порівняли їх із
сучасними Олімпійськими іграми, щоб побачити, як вони
змінилися,
і, звичайно, у вас було домашнє завдання,
ваше домашнє завдання полягало в тому, щоб скласти речення
про  що ви могли чи не могли робити, коли
ви були дитиною,
а тепер ви можете робити це, наприклад,
коли я був дитиною, я міг лазити по
деревах,
але тепер я не можу тут ми використовуємо
минулу форму модального дієслова can
could та номер речення  два, коли я
був дитиною,
я не вмів добре готувати, але тепер, сподіваюся,
зможу, тому
наступним завданням було записати
всі власні назви з попереднього
уроку,
які ви запам'ятали,
і це ці слова, ми знаємо, що
власні імена це імена деяких
конкретна
подія або конкретна особа особливе
місце, наприклад олімпійські ігри
олімпійські ігри - це власна назва,
тому ми пишемо з
великої літери це особлива подія
олімпійські ігри або олімпіада олімпія
це місто греція це
країна афіни  також місто зевс це
ім'я
бога північна та південна америка європа
африка азія австралія це назви
континентів також власні назви
та японія бразилія китай франція та
об'єднане
королівство назви країн ми також пишемо
їх з великої
літери, тому що вони  власні назви і
далі, як зазвичай, на початку уроку
ми проводимо
невеликий, але швидкий тест
добре, ви повинні вибрати
тут, а між чотирма
можна чи не міг
Мартін кататися добре,
він повинен багато вправлятися,
який буде ваш варіант, не
можу кататися на ковзанах  тому що він не вміє добре кататися,
він повинен багато тренуватися, це
порада
для Мартіна, який не вміє добре кататися на ковзанах
добре наступний один
Марта намалюй
малюнки, коли їй було п'ять років,
твій батько
міг би малювати малюнки, коли їй було п'ять
років  це минула форма зразкового
дієслова can, тому ми
вибираємо could наступний
том дійсно атлетичний він
бігає дуже швидко
, ти там, і
він може бігати дуже швидко, тому
він атлетичний, а останній
три в  ряд, є питання,
він їздить на велосипеді, коли йому було три роки,
ні, але він правий триколісний велосипед
біля їхнього кінця,
все було в минулому, тому
правильний варіант: чи міг він їздити на
велосипеді, коли йому було три роки,
ні, він не міг  але він міг їздити
на триколісному велосипеді всі ці дії були в
минулому
і ще деякі види спорту екстремальні я
хотів би представити вам сьогодні це
підводне плавання з
аквалангом це вид спорту, де вам потрібно
спеціальне обладнання, щоб дихати під
водою з
аквалангом, тому назва  це підводне
плавання,
ви можете побачити багато цікавого
під водою
добре банджі-джампінг банджі-джампінг
це дуже небезпечно я думаю, що це
екстремальний також екстремальний вид спорту
це стрибки зверху,
але ви з'єднуєте його великим еластичним
шнуром добре наступний
стрибок з парашутом ви можете  пірнати у воду,
але ви також можете пірнути в небо
це стрибки з літака
з парашутом стрибки з парашутом надзвичайно
небезпечні і, можливо,
занадто дорогий паркур це дуже
популярний і
захоплюючий  спорт серед підлітків
і вам потрібно дістатися з одного місця в
інше найефективнішим і хитрим способом
немає обладнання, ви не бачите, що немає
обладнання,
обладнання це саме місто
, це екстремальні види спорту, а тепер я
хотів би  грайте з вами в
гру на пам'ять, просто повторіть назви
цього порту, і тоді
одна картинка зникне, і ви
будете продовжувати
її повторювати добре
стрибки з
парашутом
стрибки з парашутом паркур
і підводне плавання стрибки з парашутом
тарзанки
підводне плавання з аквалангом, паркур і банджі-джампінги,
добре, зараз час
трохи порухатися. Ви пам'ятаєте нашу невелику
вправу, я називаю, я даю вам назву
виду спорту, який ми використовуємо під час гри,
і ви плескаєте в долоні, коли я даю
вам назву  вид спорту,
який ми використовуємо з go you
mind going and the sport with do
we won ліворуч і сухо добре я даю вам
скейтборд так
ідіть скейтборд плавання
так ми йдемо плавати йога
йога  зігнутий вліво, вигнути вправо
, це правда добре баскетбол
хлопайте в долоні в груди
також хлопайте в долоні бокс
так, ми займаємося боксом, добре
і паркур, ми також займаємося
паркуром, запам'ятайте це добре.
ви і ви бачите,
що це баскетбол,
які літери тут пропущені
так k, а
далі це
стрибки у висоту стрибки у висоту,
яка буква відсутня
так h і u
наступна добре,
яка літера відсутня
c скелелазіння
відсутні дві літери
c і b зверніть увагу, що  b
це не вимовляється ця буква ми говоримо
альпінізм
альпінізм b це не вимовляється
віндсерфінг
i і ти
катаєшся на лижах
закінчується, ось чому буква i відсутня
і скайдайвінг скайдайвінг
так y і я
добре, наступний податок для вас - це відповідність
зламаним видам спорту, які ми
маємо  ось дві колонки ця перша частина
та друга частина,
і давайте поєднаємо ці зламані види спорту
добре спочатку підводне плавання
так підводне плавання наступне
харчування стіна
скейтбординг бейсбол
катання на ковзанах
сноуборд
так,
стрибки у висоту та стрибки з
парашутом, добре, так що у нас є
всі ці види спорту підряд підводне
плавання футбол скейтбординг
бейсбол катання на ковзанах або
фігурне катання сноуборд
стрибки у висоту та стрибки з парашутом,
а тепер я хочу, щоб ви
послухали історію Сашіну історію, ви знаєте, що
саша моя
подруга з Великобританії,
вона розповість вам історію про свій
улюблений
вид спорту в школі, тому
спочатку послухайте, а потім ми виконаємо кілька
завдань,
добре,
я збираюся поговорити з вами про
спорт в моїй школі,
спорт поділяється на дівчаток і
хлопчиків
Один з моїх улюблених видів спорту в моїй школі
- це
нетбол, нетбол - це в основному, коли ти
намагаєшся вбити м'яч у ворота, але
є поворот, коли
ти не можеш рухатися з м'ячем. Інша
гра, в яку я граю в школі,
- це хокей
палицю і м'яч,
і ви намагаєтеся ввести м'яч у ворота
за допомогою ключки і хлопчики, і дівчатка грають у
цю гру
хлопчики грають у гру, яка називається регбі, регбі – це
змагальна командна гра,
яка може спричинити серйозні проблеми  juries
ще одна гра, в яку ми граємо в школі,
крикет
крикет для дівчат і хлопчиків і
містить хвіртку, биту і м'яч,
дякую за перегляд добре,
дякую, що послухали, але тепер я хочу, щоб
ви послухали її знову,
і ми напишемо кілька нових слів  те, що ми зустріли
в цьому
тексті, давайте звернемо увагу на ці слова,
розділені на хлопчики і дівчатка,
означає, що хлопчики і дівчатка проводять
заняття в різних місцях,
добре, так що далі
є поворот, є поворот
, є поворот у грі, в основному,
насправді саша  два рази використав це слово
принцип принципу неприязні
ми використовуємо його лише для того, щоб частина нашої
промови була разом,
може спричинити цей вид спорту може спричинити
серйозні травми.
О
, я хочу, щоб ви послухали цю історію ще раз,
і ми виконаємо деякі завдання, з якими
я збираюся поговорити  ви про
спорт у моїй школі, види спорту
поділяються на дівчат і хлопчиків.
Один з моїх улюблених видів спорту в моїй школі
-
нетбол, нетбол - це в основному, коли ви
намагаєтеся вбити м'яч у ворота,
але є поворот, який ви не можете рухати з
У м'яч
ще одна гра, в яку я граю в школі - це хокей,
хокей - це в основному, коли у
вас є ключка і м'яч, і ви намагаєтеся ввести
м'яч у ворота
за допомогою ключки. І хлопчики, і дівчатка грають у
цю гру
хлопчики грають у гру, яка називається регбі, регбі
змагальна командна гра,
яка може спричинити серйозні травми.
Інша гра, в яку ми граємо в школі,
крикет
крикет призначена для дівчат і хлопчиків і
містить хвіртку, биту та м’яч,
дякую за перегляд.
речення і дайте мені правду, якщо це правда,
а якщо це неправда, якщо це неправда, баскетбол
- це улюблений вид спорту Саші
в школі, це правда
баскетбол - улюблений
вид спорту в школі улюблений вид спорту Саші
в школі ні,
це неправда, її улюблений вид спорту в
школі
- нетбол спорт номер два
у такій школі розділені на хлопчиків і
дівчаток чи це правда
так, ви праві це правда,
вони окремо хлопчики та дівчатка в
цій школі
ви не можете рухатися з м'ячем у
сітці, ви не можете m  ове з м'ячем
у нетболі це правда
так це правда це насправді поворот
це поворот у цій грі ви не можете
рухатися з м'ячем номер чотири вам потрібні
ракетка і м'яч для хокею
чи це правда
ні це неправда, вам потрібна ключка
і м'яч, щоб добре  добре далі
тільки хлопчики грають у хокей
тільки хлопчики грають у хокей у такій школі
чи це правда
ні це неправда хлопчики та дівчатка можуть грати в
хокей у такій школі
наступне регбі може спричинити серйозні
травми чи правда так, це правда, і це
причина,
чому тільки  хлопчики грають у регбі в такій
школі,
і останнє,
щоб грати в крикет, вам потрібні злі фламінго і м'яч,
чи це правда,
ні, це неправда, звичайно, вам потрібні
зла бита і м'яч, щоб грати в крикет,
добре, і подивіться ще раз на цей
текст і дізнайтеся,
який новий  спорт чи просто спорт
у нас є тут
добре так спорт, про який згадав Саша,
це нетбол нетбол
хокей
регбі регбі та крикет
давайте зосередимося на них нетбол
які правила нетболу
ти граєш у нетбол і намагаєшся
забити м'яч у ворота  але є основний
поворот: ви ловите м'яч,
тримайте його, але ви не можете рухатися з м'ячем,
добре,
далі добре, але це не хокей,
ви бачите, це гра в хокей поза командою
на спеціальному зеленому полі у
вас є м'яч і  ви
намагаєтеся забити м'яч
у ворота за допомогою ключки, ви бачите, що
хлопчики та
дівчатка можуть грати в цю гру
наступну гру в
регбі, тому що ця гра
може спричинити серйозні травми, це
командна гра для змагань,
але вона може спричинити серйозні травми
mojo the clickati серйозно
це  чому хлопчики грали в цю гру добре,
а остання - крикет крикет
- це гра для хлопчиків і дівчаток,
вона містить wicked the sticky
wicket, спеціальні ramuch kitaki bats,
бити і м'яч, дуже схожі дуже
близькі до американського
бейсболу, дуже близькі, але це не те
саме
і зараз  будь ласка, дайте відповідь на це запитання,
давайте дізнаємося інформацію,
яку Саша повідомила нам у своїй промові під номером
один
, види спорту розділені на хлопчиків і дівчаток
у такій
школі спорт розділений
так, вони розділені  добре
який улюблений вид спорту Саші в її
школі
так улюблений вид спорту
Саші - нетбол в чому головна поворот цієї
гри ти зрозумів так ти не можеш
рухатися з м'ячем що тобі потрібно, щоб грати в
хокей
у такій школі що ти займаєшся  потрібно
грати в хокей,
вам потрібно мати ключку та м'яч,
відмінно - це регбі командна гра
так, звичайно, це командна змагальна
гра,
чому в цю гру грають тільки хлопчики, чому в
цю гру грають тільки хлопчики
так, тому що це може викликати серйозний
гнів і для якої гри
вам потрібен злий м'яч і ставка,
для якої гри вам потрібне це обладнання
так для крикету, але зверніть увагу,
що крикет не крокет, це звучить
дуже схоже,
але крикет це ця гра, а
це крокетт крокет, у вас
також є м'яч, у вас є ця
хвіртка, але  у вас також є ці
кефалі,
і вам потрібно закинути м'яч у хвіртку,
добре, і ви, можливо, пам'ятаєте цього знаменитого
королівського
крокетта з історії про Алісу в країні чудес
Льюїса Керролла, це королівський
крокет, яку
грала Аліса  роман
, до речі, з фламінго добре,
і я хотів би показати вам
цікаву гру, яку винайшла
Луїза Керролл, це гра, це
гра Льюїса Керролла,
як зробити автобус з
машини з машини, змінивши лише
одну літеру або як зробити
чоловіки з хлопчика, змінивши лише одну літеру
, це цікаво так, давайте подивимося,
як зробити це
автомобіль, ми змінюємо цю букву
r на t у нас є кіт,
потім ми змінюємо
c на b ми ставимо,
тоді ми змінюємо a на u у нас є
але і  зрештою,
змінивши останню літеру, ми маємо автобус,
тому ми зробили автобус із
автомобіля, змінивши лише одну літеру, і кожне
слово існує в англійській мові,
тому ми також можемо зробити чоловіка з хлопчика, давайте
зробимо це разом,
хлопчик іграшка, а потім
тон тон важкий, багато  з кілограмів
десять чоловіків і чоловіків
добре, ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб зробити так, щоб дати від взяти,
і, як зазвичай, наприкінці нашого уроку у
нас є дивна гра. Ви коли-небудь
чули,
чи чули ви коли-небудь, що ми називаємо
butchule pro quidditch,
звичайно, ви  чув про
квідич, тому що це старий  я
з відомої книги про Гаррі Поттера так,
у романі в книзі у них є цей
літаючий м'яч, і у них є мітли,
і реальне життя воно існує, вони також
використовують мітли, м'ячі та обручі,
добре, і
ваше домашнє завдання ваше домашнє завдання полягатиме в тому,
щоб записати  невелике есе
про ваш улюблений вид спорту або вашу
улюблену гру
у вашій школі з використанням цього плану.
Це план, який ви можете використати, щоб написати
це
есе, ви можете знайти цей план
у відео на YouTube, тож давайте
переглянемо план я люблю спорт,
тому що
він робить  я підходжу, це робить мене здоровим,
сильним або дисциплінованим. Ви можете вибрати
свій варіант
номер два, я граю, займаюся
або ходжу щось у моїй школі,
але мій улюблений вид спорту,
і ти вибираєш свій, ти скажи свій
улюблений,
тому що мені подобаються командні ігри,
індивідуальні види спорту або мені подобається  перебуваючи на
свіжому повітрі або мені подобаються ігри в приміщенні
або з будь-якої іншої причини,
ви наводите причину та пояснюєте, чому вам
подобається цей вид спорту,
вам потрібен інвентар
для цієї гри або щоб спорт був
безпечним
тут, ви  щойно згадав про обладнання
для цієї гри,
щоб виграти цю гру, вам потрібно забити гол або забити м'яч у кошик або у ворота, тому
це невелика
частина про правила цієї гри. Коротко
про правила цієї гри чи виду спорту, які
ви можете  або не вмієш щось робити,
наприклад,
ловити м'яч чи кидати м'яч, передавати
чи бити м'яч,
коли ти граєш у цю гру, це також
те, що ти можеш або не можеш робити
у своєму улюбленому виді спорту, я думаю чи
для мене це небезпечно
чи  це не небезпечно це небезпечно,
тому що
ви можете легко отримати травму, ви можете
легко отримати травму або розтягнути щиколотку,
або отримати синяк або навіть зламати ногу
або руку і останнє речення, щоб бути хорошим
у спорті,
ви повинні багато тренуватися, ви повинні наполегливо працювати
або  ви повинні потренуватися дивитися,
тож це кінець нашого уроку,
дякую до побачення та будьте здорові та
щасливі
[Музика]
ви